bonsoir c'est avec plaisir que nous
ouvrons ce dernier journal de l'année
sur une bonne nouvelle la confirmation
de l'ouverture de négociations au sujet
de l'avenir de l'imprimerie du quotidien
dijonnais les dépêches
nous vous l'annoncions déjà hier sans
pouvoir donner le contenu de l'accord
entre le syndicat du livre cgt et
monsieur ligne aile
c'est peut-être la fin d'un des conflits
les plus durs qui est connue la presse
après la décision du pdg lyonnais de
transférer l'impression du journal
dijonnais dans son usine de chassieu
près de lyon le 19 août les bases de
l'accord un projet d'achat de
l'imprimerie par une coopérative
ouvrière le transfert des marchés
permettant de faire tourner les machines
et l'abandon des plaintes déposées
contre les occupants et